chase anderson 32 years old will make
his second start of the season through
the ball well his first time out against
boston he threw three innings he's a guy
that has pitched well he's seven years
in the big leagues with a 53 and 40
record two out base runner for the race
g-man choi went over four with three
strikeouts last night dropping his
average down to 185. choice swings and
lines went to straightaway center
there's randall grichik making the catch
choi's retired so are the rays yarnbro
has pitched very well against the blue
jays over his career he has in one
record lead off man aboard biggio at
first and the delivery swing and a miss
he struck him out and there's yarbrough
getting bushed a little anxious and
getting into chase down in the dirt and
he retires him on three pitches so two
on with two out for vladimir guerrero jr
swing of the messi got him to chase the
chain jumped down he got him anxious
just like he did bechet a couple of
strikeouts and a couple of runners left
the lead off man on here in the second
and now the shortstop willie adams and
right there at the knees for strike
three called again the 1-2 and a
fastball at the knees to get him
back-to-back strikeouts for anderson the
rays have runners on the corners with
two down
first pitch swinging popped up anderson
is trying to help maguire find it it'll
be guerrero coming down the line to make
the basket catch here is austin meadows
to lead off
all right fly ball back into right
that will carry and go austin meadows
with his second home run of 2020 and
he's given the raise a one-nothing lead
here in the third so two out in a runner
at second for the red-hot mike brasso
loud the lead another o2 a swing and a
miss got him with a cutter and chase
anderson strikes out brasso bo buchet
four straight games with a home run 1-1
ground ball left side and it's going to
get under the gloves of both infielders
that's going to be a base hit to extend
his hit streak so with two outs and
runners at first and third here's
hernandez to base it his first time he's
a 3-2 offering to hernandez and he
swings and drives one in the air to
center but kiermeier is right there to
make the catch and that will retire the
side so the blue jays threaten but leave
two men aboard for the second time
tonight wilmer fought takes over for
chase anderson to start the fourth
inning with the blue jays down one
nothing half swing on a fastball up he
goes around says hunter wendelstead and
font strikes out adamus for the first
down still two and two to zanino with
two outs that's the important thing and
there's a swing and a miss and font
strikes him out blue jays and the rays
are unfortunately going into a rain
delay the ground screw is getting the
tarp on the field it is the first rain
delay for blue jays home game 17 years
ready for more baseball as the blue jays
and the rays resume the game that was
suspended by weather yesterday jalen
beaks will begin this resumption of the
game and mooji saw him on opening night
that'll bring up rowdy toles
here's a chopper and it's going to get
through the drawn in infield into center
field and that'll go as an rbi single
for teles to tie the game that's the way
to put the ball in play up to demon choi
left hand battered there's a swinging
hard ground ball to first into right for
a base hit it heads towards the corner
diaz motors around second he heads for
third lanaris is going to give him a
late stop sign then the throw gets away
and heading home as diaz he will score
standing up and choi makes it to third
botched defense for the blue jays and
the rays take a two to one lead now
kevin cash coming out to talk with the
umpers because i'm not sure if that ball
got away or what if it ended up in the
dugout area and trying to see if the
ball having says it went into the dugout
should you get that bag so we'll see who
they give the error to it's got to be
the biggio i think and then i think the
umpires are going to look to see
where troy was if he was around second
base
then you wonder if he gets
third and home
and so they'll take a look at the high
home camera
to see where he was when that throw got
away we see the replay again here
it did and
the raise base runners were given only
the additional 90 feet so i got to go
base it e4 to give the raise the lead
and now the empires are checking to see
if choi was around second or if he was
just standing at second base well
they're being told something or at least
communicating he did start running
towards third only once the throw that
away the umpires are now saying that
choice stays at third base
so diaz scores the raise two have a two
to one lead enjoy the runner at third
with two out with the s scoring because
of the error so now with two down to
oscar hernandez didn't get it there but
he hooks the ball to left field and it's
down for a base hit it'll get all the
way to the fence where meadows picks it
up panic is on his way to third getting
a wave home there will be no relay throw
and the blue jays have tied it it was
easy for the blue jays to score panic
all the way from first players another
good swing danny's never faced aaron
luke he's swung out and lifted it's
yellow center caremeyer coming on twice
and makes the catch
got a great break and a good read and
went into a slide and it's taken away by
the best center fielder in the business
and brandon allowed to lead off against
the right-hander romano fly ball back
into center of the bat of lao with kerry
good
bye
home run for brandon lau
and the rays take the lead his seventh
home run of the year and it's 3-2 rays
have nick anderson on the mound as we
head into the bottom of the ninth inning
and he lifts it into center
kirmar sets up to make the catch and the
rays win it they have completed the
second game of this series and they win
it three to two on the home run by
brandon lau to lead off the top of the
ninth inning